So we've been tracking very closely this extraordinarily
concerning authoritarian slide by Donald Trump,
where he is now asserting to have absolute
power over governors and over what governors
tell businesses and schools within their states
to do.
The context is all reopening the economy from
Corona virus.
And Donald Trump signaling yesterday during
his press briefing that there is somewhere
between 20 and 29 states that he believes
very soon, even before potentially the April
30th social distancing deadline, may be able
to start to open up.
There are states that have already said we're
not going to listen to Trump, we're going
to do what our public health officials say.
And Donald Trump has now asserted multiple
times that he has absolute authority over
the states.
Here's one example from Monday's press briefing.
What you're trying.
No, not at all.
Let let let me just a very simple I'm going
to put it very simply.
The president of the United States has the
authority to do what the president has the
authority to do, which is very powerful.
The president of the United States calls the
shots.
If we weren't here for the states, you would
have had a problem in this country like you've
never seen before.
We were here to back them up and we're back
in with more than back them up.
We did a job that nobody ever thought was
possible.
It's a decision for the president of the United
States.
Now, with that being said, we're going to
work with the states because it's very important.
You have local governments, they have pinpointed
it's really you talk about it's like a microchip.
They have pinpointed we have local government
that hopefully will do a good job.
And if they don't do a good job, I'd step
in so fast.
But no, they can't do anything without the
approval of the president.
Here's another specific question from another
reporter.
And Trump is just not backing down.
He wants to be the authoritarian.
He also wants to avoid responsibility when
things go wrong.
But he wants to be the authoritarian.
Take a look at your understanding of your
authority.
To be governors.
Just be very specific.
For instance, if a governor issued a stay
at home and you say my authority, the president
is a threat, might because it's not me.
This is when somebody is the president of
the United States.
The authority is total.
And that's the way it's gotta be.
Your authority is just total.
It's total.
And the governors know that.
So if the governor said you have a couple
of bands of excuse me.
Excuse me.
You have a cup.
Could you receive that order?
You have a couple of bands of of Democrat
governors, but they will agree to it.
They will agree to put the authority of the
president of the United States having to do
with the subject we're talking.
But his total.
And then lastly, here's CNN's Caitlin Collins
pressing him and asking, has has.
Where did you get this idea?
Who told you that you have this absolute authority
over governors?
And has any governor said they agree that
you have this authority?
You just said you said when someone is president
of the United States, he is turtle.
That is not true.
Yes.
You know.
We're going to write up papers on this.
It's not going to be necessary because the
governors need us one way or the other.
Because ultimately, it comes with the federal
government.
That being said, we're getting along very
well with the governors.
And I feel very certain that there won't be
a problem.
Yes, please go.
Governor, I'm sorry that you have the authority
to decide when there is an answer to why.
Because I don't have to search the president's
internal long enough.
Trump obviously not really giving an answer.
So yesterday I told you.
It's not even clear that a governor can force
a business to open like can Charlie Baker
here in Massachusetts.
Go to my favorite sushi and Indian food restaurants
and say you have to open.
I don't think that he can.
So the idea that the president can force the
governors to make businesses do those things
is a joke.
But now that we've had another 24 hours, the
constitutional law experts have weighed in.
And not only does Trump lack the powers he
claims to have.
The constitution is actually very clear that
he can't do what he says he is able to do.
And both Republicans and Democrats who are
thinking about this clearly seem to be on
the same page.
Here's Republican Congresswoman Liz Cheney,
the daughter of the diabolical former vise
President Dick Cheney.
She tweeted that, quote, The federal government
does not have absolute power.
The powers not delegated to the United States
by the Constitution nor prohibited by it to
the states are reserved to the states, respectively,
or to the people.
That's the 10th Amendment to the Constitution.
Now, Trump frequently will mention federalism
when he talks about why he has this absolute
power.
He'll say this often during the White House
coronavirus press briefings and he pretends
to understand what it means.
But federalism in practice tells us the president
can tell state governors what to do other
than in the very specific areas outlined in
the Constitution.
Now, it is true that in times of emergency,
presidents have tried to figure out how to
boss governors around.
But they failed to do it.
During the Korean War, Harry Truman declared
a national emergency, seized private steel
mills, tried to prevent preempt steelworkers
from striking, argued the mills are essential
to national defense and the Supreme Court
actually decided the other way.
In a case called Youngstown, Youngstown, Va.,
I forget the name of Youngstown something.
So this has been tested and it's not gone
the federal government's way.
Now there's another important element Trump
never shut the country down.
He just didn't do it.
How can Trump reopen something he didn't close
in the first place?
Whether Trump could shut down the country
by directing governors to do it is question.
One answer is it doesn't seem that he can
do it.
But in practice, Trump never shut down states.
Governors made decisions at different points
in time, and it's up to governors to decide
to reopen.
What we have is a wannabe dictator on our
hands and sadly, when the Senate pre-judged
trumps impeachment and decided we're acquitting
him before the trial even started, they actually
reinforced the notion that Trump can do anything.
And Trump has said Article 2 of the Constitution
says, I can do whatever I want.
Trump may well believe this.
He hasn't actually demonstrated it legally.
But in practice, what consequences have there
been?
You know, when Trump.
Trump's not supposed to violate the emoluments
clause, but he did it.
And there haven't been consequences.
Trump has done it with no consequences, the
entire presidency.
And this is why it's so important to remove
this clown in November.
The law is not on Trump's side here.
And in many other cases, the constitution
is not on Trump's side here and in many other
cases.
But he's been getting away with whatever he
wants for more than three years at this point.
And there have been no repercussions other
than a few of his former friends having to
go to prison for a few years.
He has done damage as a result of being essentially
immune to consequences.
And he's just going to keep doing it until
we remove him.
If we do so in November, we'll talk a little
later about Bernie's recent comments about
this, former President Obama's recent comments
about it.
But in the meantime, let me know where you
fall on this issue of Trump versus the governors
on who has the right, the power, the authority
that Trump claims to have.
I think it's pretty clear constitutional experts
seem to think it's very clear.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
Let me know what you think.